hi everyone this is jeremy shieffling
from khan academy
hope you're having a good hump day i
know we're kind of in a hump season
right now trying to get over this big
thing as a society so i appreciate you
making time out of everything going on
in your lives both professionally and
personally to be with us and speaking of
that i have to give a huge shout out to
chris cosberg here because chris is not
only a dedicated special education
teacher in arizona he's also the father
of three kids five and under
so when we talk about work-life balance
chris is juggling as many balls in the
air as you can imagine
and so we really appreciate you taking
time out of all that chaos to share your
expertise with us today chris
absolutely happy to be here
so just to give folks a sense of where
you're coming from tell us a little bit
about sort of
what you do as an educator in normal
times and then how you're coping today
given these very abnormal times we live
in
so on a day-to-day basis outside of a
pandemic i do
special education math specifically i
have an ela counterpart
and i do
this year i'm doing seventh and eighth
grade last year i did fourth or eighth
grade
um and so i do a little bit of pull out
but most of my stuff is pushing
helping support the students and the
teachers
cool
and how are things starting to shift for
you as we've gone to this remote
learning environment all of a sudden
especially given special education
students
um special education students for me uh
it hasn't changed a lot
i'm meeting more one-on-one
rather than like groups of three or four
i'm just having kids schedule their time
but before the pandemic started i was
using khan academy to track and
do goal progress stuff with the students
and allow them to
track their own progress and be aware of
what they need to be working on
so that part of it hasn't changed a lot
for me
um from pre pandemic to currently
cool i love that you're still that
lifeline for students even on a
one-on-one basis because i know that's
hard to scale but so important for
students
yeah um
and i haven't been pushing it a ton
because they have so much other stuff
going on
um so it's been a few emails just
checking in
i've done a few video conferencing
uh experiences with them which have been
interesting um but yeah you know just
letting them know that i'm here if they
need to talk
if they need to see my face if that's
helpful
and then just reminders that they can
still access
and i still need them to access that
stuff that they've been doing on con
before they're pandemic
cool and talk to us a little bit about
sort of what your expectations are with
khan academy especially in this moment
so that folks who are trying to
replicate that for maybe the first time
can get a sense of how to approach it
um so khan academy
in terms of special education how i use
it
all the kids that are on my service
roster are in my class
and it's i think the name changes every
year this year it might just be cosberg
so they're all in my class
and then from there
i assign them specific standard
based on their goals in their ieps
so if i have i think i have a caseload
of 14 this year
so i assign 14 students different
uh
assignments based on their goal so if i
have a eighth grader
who's working on one-step equations
their assignments will be gauged towards
what one-step equations
and then um one of the things i really
like about khan academy is i can
scaffold them up to that
so i might assign just
combining like terms
and they show that they master those
different components of solving
equations i give them the actual
equations
cool and just sort of illustrate what
you're talking about here obviously you
can make assignments from your khan
academy classroom or you can search for
the exact thing that you want to hand
out
search for exercises in that area
and then assign it not just to your
whole class but to individual students
so you get that sort of differentiation
that you are alluding to there
and one of the most helpful things for
me
is
when i
when i've fit and written that iep and
it's enforced i'll go on con
and i'll assign
the
standardized assignments that they need
and then i'll change the due dates based
on when i want them due so it like
progresses them towards that year end
goal
so they
so then i have it set up right away
um and so like on this
when this pandemic started all my kids
were already set up
full year of
um
instruction because i did it at the very
beginning
very cool and so even for folks who are
just getting started in this moment you
can absolutely catch up with chris in
the sense of getting your students onto
khan academy by handing out that course
link or using google classroom if you
have it and then you can start to give
these differential assignments
i know a lot of teachers are really
curious what you do next like what are
your expectations for how fast an
assignment should be done
do you grade it do you give feedback
so
it depends on every student right not
every kid is going to go through their
assignments
at the same pace
i come at it from
i have
an assignment that i want them to be
able to master by the end of the year
and so my due dates are pretty flexible
because what i'm looking for most is
that skill mastery yeah um
and even if it's taking a long time
that's still giving me data
and so what i talk with my students
about
is
one of the best things about khan is i
try again
where they can do it
and i can see their score and they can
see their score
and we can go over
that assignment and then they can try it
again
to let them know that
just because they did it and got a
certain score that doesn't mean they're
done they have to keep learning it and
they have to keep
they have to keep
that understanding with them
as they move forward
so i really like the try again option
one of my favorite things
is when i go on and i see the kid has
tried 14 times
and then i go up to him like this is
awesome that you keep trying it um
because we
my school in particular we we really
preach that growth mindset
and it's hard to have that growth
mindset on worksheets
it's just a lot of work to do worksheets
over and over again in my mind
um
i find the students a lot more willing
to try those five questions or those
seven questions again
um
because it's it's easier than
the worksheets in my opinion
cool i love that and i think probably
now more than ever growth mindset is so
essential for every student
all across the country all around the
world who's now basically being asked to
keep pushing in the face of adversity
and khan academy actually has a bunch of
activities and exercises you can share
with your students even right away
that being said
um
when you share out these assignments
with students
how do you keep them motivated i know
this sort of speaks to the growth
mindset piece but like a lot of teachers
have been asking okay motivation is even
hard in my physical classroom now with
distance between us
how do i keep people engaged even in the
face of everything that we're never up
against
um
one of the things that i've found
motivating for the students is that when
like i tell them they have to reach a
certain score
and and then they can be done and they
just they can move on to the next thing
and to me
the students being able to progress at
their own pace
is motivation like
they can
be done as quickly as they want to be
done depending on how much effort
they're putting in and how focused and
and all that so i think just the self
pace of khan academy is more
motivational for the kids
cool and so to that point will you
assign multiple assignments at a time so
that students can work ahead if they
want to
as well as focus on just one if they
need that mastery
yeah so
i usually have
like i said for my for the students with
the math goals
i have them set with periodic dates and
so it's like these ones need to be done
by this time these need to be done by
this time
but as soon as they're done they can
move on and so
like
i'll have kids that finish all that
stuff and have showed mastery of their
iep goal before the year is up um which
is just a huge point of celebration
uh for them and then we can continue
working
um
to to continue progressing
cool so definitely different ways to
slice and dice it and also give students
that runway so they can really start to
take autonomous ownership over their
learning um
okay so at this point i actually want to
switch gears a little bit and take it
over to questions directly from the
audience and thank you to everyone who's
been sharing those already
if you haven't seen it yet you can ask
questions directly to chris and get them
answered live by going to the questions
feature of the go to webinar control
panel and right now i'm seeing questions
from kathy
and carrie and jean and we're gonna just
take those as they come in so submit
questions whatever's on your mind chris
is brave enough to take them on left
right and center
okay
so
um i think kathy's first question is
being answered a little bit here she
says i'm a grade one teacher but i have
students in my class who are the
kindergarten level or grade two level
for certain skills
how do i make sure that every student is
getting what they need even with those
different levels
i think that's kind of what you were
talking about with one by one
assignments
yeah so you can assign
if you have your
students grouped by ability level or
however you haven't grouped
you can assign specific students so as
you're seeing on the screen you can pick
what students
are given what assignments
so
you can have
a third of your class on the
kindergarten level standard that you're
working on in your first grade class you
can have a 30-year kids on that first
grade standard that you're working on
and you can have a third of your kids
working on that second grade level
standard
so khan academy is
beautiful in the way that you can
differentiate and scaffold
for all of your students
cool all right so i think that speaks to
that thanks for the great question kathy
um you're getting a little love here
chris from andrea and anastasia your fan
club is growing so we wanted to thank
you for um sharing this awesome advice
today um
let's see here ooh kathy's asking
another good question
um is there a way to help students who
are not confident especially about their
reading skills given so much of khan is
reading based you know questions are
sort of offered in this text-based
format have you ever had to deal with
that with your students chris
um
i have a couple students that that
struggle uh reading and they on google
chrome
there's just the setting where it can
read the text to them so i've they've
they've been using like the computer
settings to have that read to them
um
if you're talking about like right now
and you maybe
wouldn't be able to
walk them through how to turn on that
audio
um it could be something
i've had a student already on uh
during this pandemic
log on and she was struggling with slope
and she shared her screen with me and so
i was able to like talk her through it
while seeing what she was doing and so
that would be an option maybe um
she's working with first grade so that
might be
difficult
um
i don't know that's younger than i
usually work with i know my
kindergartner uh she's been doing khan
academy kids and just in this pandemic
she has started doing khan academy as
her reading has gotten better
but she did khan academy kids
when when she was struggling to read
what khan academy was talking about and
she really loved that
um my two-year-old those khan academy
kids and that's more geared towards i
think kids that maybe struggle with
reading because it's not as
literary yeah i'll do a second that like
my own six-year-old who says oh khan
academy kids is for little kids actually
loves it compared to khan academy the
regular version oh yeah just because
again it's like really easy to engage it
sort of reads aloud for you and it gets
the student hooked right from the
beginning versus all the sort of upfront
setup especially for early elementary
students so highly recommend checking
that out if you're teaching that
audience
yeah and khan academy kids has like
uh their social emotional health like
khan academy kids is like a whole
whole child program in and of itself and
i won't get into that because i could um
but that might be another option you
want to look into if your kids struggle
with the reading part of it
cool i love that okay great questions
kathy and thank you chris for handling
those so well
um
jean is asking a really good question
and i've heard this from a lot of
teachers that maybe speaks to the equity
issue or just sort of the complexity of
the times we're living in
but gina has been sending out
assignments to all of her students
some of them have joined her classroom
and started to do them
others have not actually signed up yet
is there some way especially given that
we're in this remote learning
environment where you can get those
students over the hump and get them into
your classroom or is there a way to
reach students who aren't even signed up
with khan academy
that's gonna be hard to do remotely um
i always have the kids sign up with
their like school email so like our
school district has every kid has like a
google
or gmail
um and so they have like
google docs and stuff so i always have
them click sign in with google and that
makes it simpler it's like one less
password and username to remember um so
i don't know if that applies to you that
might might help
simplify the signup process
um
as far as getting content out to them
on khan academy you can assign
assignments where it's every student
sees the same questions
and so that might be an option where you
can go through that assignment where
all the kids that are already signed in
will be seeing the same questions as you
and you could record going through that
and maybe email it
out to the kids so they're seeing the
same questions and getting the same
content
um
that's the tough question though is like
how do you get these kids online when
you're not sitting right there with them
helping them get online
um
yeah our district is like sending home
paper packets for kids that don't have
online access it's
i don't know you could try to send it
video in it maybe would be my suggestion
with all the same questions
and then uh
emailing it now
yeah totally um i think you nailed it
there chris because it is a tough thing
to do even in class let alone with this
distance in between us
one little hack that offer out there is
if you're just having sort of uh trouble
getting folks really registered through
that whole process
and you just need to get them doing
something soon so they don't sort of
build those gaps into their foundations
you will be able to notice that for
every single piece of content in khan
academy there is actually a separate url
so for example if you want to share out
this video
or these lessons all about
growth mindset you could literally just
copy and paste that url into an email
into remind in the class dojo however
you normally communicate with students
and families
and they can access it without even
registering for khan academy now you
don't get the great tracking and
progress reports but at the very least
you get less friction in the process and
the easier sort of place to start
yeah that's a great point and um
you don't have to have a login to be
able to do khan academy which is awesome
it's entirely free and it's crazy
um
so they could just do it without a login
and maybe take a picture of their score
so they can at least
send that to you or just email it to you
so you have some bit of information
um
but yeah they don't have to have a login
to access it so that link that that he
was talking about is is
everybody can access it whether they
have a
khan academy account or not
cool great question gene and chris thank
you for um speaking to that one directly
jill's got another tough one for you and
jill's curious about specifically
working with special education students
who have trouble
um
sort of processing information and
getting ready to sort of engage with
these videos can you just talk about
like what the khan academy video feature
is
how you might use it and how it might
serve students in this audience
um so when i use it i um
it depends on the ability to level the
students a lot of the students i work
with i can tell them to
um
watch the video and take notes and then
if they don't then it's something like
that's a discussion we have um one of my
favorite things about the videos is to
pop they say why don't you pause it and
try it out
um and that's a great opportunity
for the students to try and see
whether they're gauging it or not
um
let's see
the videos
based on to me it seems like this based
on the standard the grade level standard
the videos are kind of
at that grade levels attention span
um
so there
is in that it seems
um the eighth grade ones are different
than the third grade videos that i've
seen
one of the things that i talk to the
students about and we work on in seventh
and eighth grade is i kind of give them
a
taking form
that they can like follow along and fill
out because a lot of kids just don't
know how to take notes on these videos
and when they're in seventh and eighth
grade they need to know how to take
notes
um
yeah i don't know if i can answer your
question i don't know that's awesome i
think i'll just add two things um
because all these videos are actually
hosted on youtube you have two really
good features number one you have closed
captions so for students who again need
a little more support you've got that
channel available and you can always
turn down the playback speed
so if students want to watch it at three
quarters time or half time they can
certainly do that and i absolutely pause
and rewind as chris was talking about so
hopefully that gives your students some
tools in this sort of challenging
and
time
have i work with
who
struggles with math is like a gifted
reader and so
like printing off the close like the
script of the video just having her read
it it's in her
math it helps her understand it because
we're using her strength of reading
um to help with the struggle of math
um and so that's one of those things
like you said
in order to print off those transcripts
cool that's so awesome like i think one
of the things that i really want to
emphasize about khan academy is it's
really just a tool for teachers to use
based on their existing knowledge of
students
and so it's not teaching your students
for you just augmenting what you already
know to be true so if you know that your
students have certain gifts here and
certain challenges there
use the tool to fill in those gaps and
play to their strengths
um great question from david i know you
were talking before chris about
standards making sure that you're
aligned with that how do you find
standards on khan academy how do you
make sure that you're aligned
uh so there in khan academy there's a
search bar
and you can type in
a standard and the standard will pop up
or if you see on the the video that's
right there it tells you the standard
that that video is
and if you click on that right there
it'll open up
just kind of like their standards
menu and so over here on the left
are all the grades listed
um
and so if i'm working with a seventh
grade student i'll click on the seventh
grade
uh or if i'm working with the eighth
grade student i'll click on the eighth
grade
and i'll give them a little bit of
the eighth grade standard that i want
them to work on but also
if it's an eighth grade standard that
they need to master i'll give them
seventh grade and sixth grade standards
as well too to kind of build up and that
also helps me identify like
the
happening
and so from here too you can click on
scale drawings
and it'll
up
the scale drawings and this is ga1 and
so they have seven things and from here
you can click a sign
and you can assign this assignment
to
whatever students however many students
are needing 7.g81
and just like chris said you can always
if you know those standards if they're
burned into your retinas or into your
mind you can just rattle them off and
we'll just pull up exactly what you need
i've also shared that common core map in
the chat for folks who want to dig in a
little deeper
okay yeah and so that's why i do it
right after i write my iaps is because
that standard is
in my head
and so
i i just do them all
the two grade levels below and then
feeding up to the standard that they
need to master
cool
this is a higher level question sort of
specific to the world we're addressing
today
kayla wants to know
how do you tackle accommodations and
modifications in this world of khan
academy
um so i work with a couple students that
have modifications and so one of them is
in seventh grade
and so when they're solving
two two-step equations
uh i'll go to
sixth grade
and do
the sixth grade uh equivalent standards
or even the fifth grade equivalent
standards
and so that's just
the biggest thing
i mean in general with accommodations
and modifications is the relationship
you have with the
general education teacher uh if that
student is in their grade book
so like i have a great relationship with
this student's teacher and all
and and like i have a great book for him
and so
when they're working on seventh grade
equations i'm supplementing in
modified assignments
that are at a lower grade level but it's
still working on the same standards
uh if that makes sense
very cool yeah it goes back to that sort
of core thing you laid out at the
beginning which is you can pick and
choose what's right for your students
based on what you know about them versus
having to have one sort of
one-size-fits-all approach
yes and and even if
like this is the conversation i have
with jenna and students or teachers all
the time is that you can accommodate for
any student that is in your class
and so it's that's the beauty of khan
academy is that you can
if you really
standards and you know what the kids
actually have to know
can adjust from there
but khan academy is great for
accommodations and modifications
because you can assign different
standards or you can assign low grade
level standards
one of the ways we have accommodated in
seventh grade
is
uh if you go to the
so we use illustrative math and khan
academy partners with illustrative math
and so under
courses illustrative math seventh grade
um
they have
lessons for illustr
uh public school drawings you see that
there's lessons one two three five all
those lessons there
as we accommodate is the t jenna teacher
and i go through and see which ones are
the foundational
uh of lessons
and we'll
we'll we'll say
student x these lessons one two
five eleven and so we're making sure
that they're getting all the same
standards but they don't have as many of
the lessons that they have to do
superstar um
enough we've done the accommodation is
uh
adjusting that mastery level we're
asking for
um so in khan academy each assignment
has like a familiar rating a proficient
and then a mastery rating
and then the mastery rating you get if
you've done the whole unit and the unit
test
and so we
depending on the students we might
adjust where like the proficient level
is a hundred percent for that student
because we're good with the 85 80 or the
75 percent that that student is reaching
um so just adjusting that uh grade
scaling two is another way we
accommodate
and then speaking of that relationship
with the gen ed teacher ashley's asking
a really important question which is do
your students belong to multiple khan
academy classes do you share one khan
academy account with the gen ed teacher
how do you sort of do that delicate
dance
um
so
the eighth grade
teacher that i was working with we
started using khan academy more this
year and so i was more familiar with how
i created the class
on khan academy so all the students were
in there and i was using that to teach
her how to how to use it and assign
stuff
but the students were in her class and
then i also had some students who were
in academic academy with me or the
students that are on my service roster
they see they will see multiple classes
on that left side
so it might be
gen ed teachers classroom
my elective classroom and then it'll say
like
my mr cosberg students or something like
that and so the students can be in
multiple classrooms
i you might be able to speak to this a
little bit more but i haven't found a
way to have multiple teachers on one
classroom
yeah no it's a tough point um something
we're looking at right now
but if there's a co-teacher environment
you know a special education teacher and
gen ed teacher um sometimes they do
share accounts you know that's not ideal
but that's sort of where we are right
now i will just sort of show you what
the um the learner dashboard looks like
so just to give you a sense of how one
student can have multiple teachers on
khan academy
down here at the very bottom under this
teacher section you can always join any
class so if chris has his own class code
and then the gen ed teacher in eighth
grade has their own class code
that single student can easily inhabit
both classrooms without having to create
a separate account or have a separate
email address so that's probably the
easiest way to get folks started and if
you're ever curious about what the
learner view looks like just go to your
name in the upper right hand corner and
then learner home and you can see
exactly what students see
okay yeah so they'll see all their
classes and our seventh grade ela
teacher actually started using khan
academy this year too
so the kids were doing seven
math and i mean seventh grade ela inc so
they would see both of their classes
and then i'll say even
if
so if they're in the gen ed math
teacher's class
and they're one of my students
in the activity view if you go to
students and you go to activity
you can see what they're working on
whether it's for your class or someone
else's class and so that's another way
to stay up to date on whether they're
doing what they need to be doing for
gen ed math class
so you see assignments here so they
might see the stuff that i've assigned
them
under my class
and so if then if you click to activity
log you can see the videos they're
watching you can see the
exercises they're doing and you can see
the scores you can see how long they've
been taking on them
um
you can adjust the range and so
even if they're not in your class
they can add you as their teacher and
you can still see what they're doing
that's right yeah that way you have that
total sort of visibility into a
student's full experience not just your
little slice of the pie
exactly cool
well i know we're at time i know you've
got your own kids both your students and
your children to take care of chris so i
just wanted to end with one final
question which is i know there are a lot
of other questions out there across the
country
if you were going to recommend one or
two resources for folks to get help with
khan academy what's been useful for you
in your own practice
um one of the most useful things is me
going on and like doing the work i'm
asking the students to do so i
understand the experiences that they're
going through so i usually try and watch
the videos and do the assignments that
i'm asking them to do so when they have
questions i can kind of respond a little
bit better to that um especially
when we're doing things remotely and i
can't be standing next to the computer
when they have their question
um
and then i i think the biggest thing is
it's not going to be perfect like i
started out by just like trying things
on khan academy and then kind of refined
it from there
um
the kids doing like the
as long as kids are on khan academy it's
not going to hurt them i think would be
my advice like just get them on
and then i really push it as a resource
because i work i work with seventh and
eighth and so i really harp on that it's
a good resource for them when they go to
high school
because of that search tool if they
don't understand something that they're
doing in high school they can go in and
they can search that topic and they'll
see videos and they'll see exercises
um
so it's a resource if they don't
understand and it's an incredible study
tool
uh conversation i have over and over
again with the my students is that to
study math you're not just looking at
notes you have to do the problems over
and over and over again
um and and that's why it's another great
resource
i love that especially in this moment
we're all sort of like living day-to-day
crisis to crisis taking that long view
of hey
our students have a big road ahead of
them how do we set them up for success
even with the roadblocks we're facing
this moment um and kahn can definitely
be a part of that so chris i want to
thank you so much for taking time away
from your own class and your own kids to
share your expertise across the country
i want to thank everyone else for
joining in and investing time in this
session
wish you a lot of luck and success on
this tough road ahead and if there's
anything we can do to support you please
just let us know thank you so much
thanks for having me
bye all
you